the number of people infected with the
corona virus has surged past the 70
thousand mark here the latest figures
from the Chinese government it's
reporting just over two thousand new
cases today that's a slight increase
after three days of lower numbers and
there have been 105 new deaths from the
disease bringing the total number of
dead to about 1800 since the outbreak
began two months ago in other
developments DW has confirmed that CL
GaN in Hebei province is using tighter
new restrictions residents there are not
being permitted to leave their homes or
to use their private vehicles let's get
more now on those tough new measures
with correspondent Matthias Berliner
Matthias can you tell us how our
authorities making sure that people
don't leave their homes and don't get
into their cars and see oh god I can't
tell you details about that but it's not
so hard to make sure people don't leave
their houses in China as most people
leave in compounds that unfenced
compounds so you just need to control
basically the door of that compound and
then you make sure people don't walk out
in and out people there are issued
passes even here in Beijing I'm issued a
pass to enter and to leave my compound
it we are not yet restricted from going
in and out but I have to show my past
and I cannot receive visitors for
example and that's true for most people
here in Beijing we are hearing the same
from other cities so Xian shelgon and
Huang gang which is a city also nearby
these two cities are very close to Wuhan
the epicenter they have taken it a bit
further and they are now preventing
people from going out of their homes
even it for buying groceries other
cities we are hearing of in Jersey on
province several cities have restricted
the number of people for each household
who can leave and the number of times
they can leave so basically one person
is allowed to go shopping every two days
from each household so we are seeing all
kinds of restrictions all over the
country Shao Kahn is just one of the
harshest okay now Matias the president
she we understand has just delivered a
speech behind closed doors do we know
anything about that what he said then
yeah it has been published it has been
published this weekend in osho that's
the party theory newspaper and there is
lots of talk about winning this people's
war against the disease and how he is
leading it but there's one very
interesting detail he says in that
speech that he has been leading this
battle from January 7th on now still
near sevens was a time when officials
still said that the virus would not
spread between humans and when they did
not admit they had a problem so in some
way he is now taking responsibility for
this massive failure to curb the
infection at an earlier stage and that's
quite remarkable it could mean that they
are confident now of winning and this
battle against the virus although we are
not seeing any numbers on the ground
that would point to that and we are not
somebody just gave me a mask because
people when I stand here without a mask
they do they think I shouldn't so he is
basically taking responsibility and it
could mean that they are confident it
could also mean that he could not shun
the responsibility after who Hans Maher
has already said that he informed the
authorities timely so it is quite
remarkable he's taking more risk on
himself now it could also mean that it's
now all or nothing for him okay being
handed that mask
mattias a sign that people are taking
this people's war as she put it
seriously where you are in via Beijing
Matias thank you very much for that well
a quarantined cruise ship in the
Japanese port of Yokohama has seen
hundreds of American passengers
evacuated that ship has been in
quarantine for about two weeks now after
a man who disembarked in Hong Kong
tested positive for the virus
the diamond princess fenced off at the
dockside in Yokohama but for some at
least a way out after more than a week
of uncertainty buses pull up next to the
ship ready to pick up some 300 Americans
who have chosen to squat quarantine here
for quarantine back home all right this
is it I'm about to step into the big
wide world so I have to put my mask on
and get going
Sheryl malsky and her husband Paul from
Syracuse in New York State after being
cooped up on the ship for 12 days
they've agreed to be flown back to the
US where they'll spend another 14 days
in isolation they shot this cell phone
video of their own evacuation in this
case at least a good-natured event the
bustle takes you an airplane the
airplane takes you to the United States
and then you get fast for it and then
they're on the road leaving behind them
at least 40 Americans who have
contracted the virus those patients will
remain in Japan for treatment and the
last leg of the evacuation government
chartered jumbo jets ready to fly to
California and Texas an eventful holiday
is drawing to a close
wearing these massive a QA ssin
completed Canada Hong Kong and Italy say
they also plan to evacuate their
citizens from the cruise ship well
earlier we spoke to correspondent Klaus
Sheva in Tokyo we asked him about the
situation right now on the still
quarantined diamond princess Klaus Sheva
is a correspondent with a Germany's
public broadcaster ard in Tokyo joins us
now for more g'day to you Klaus um can
you tell us what's the situation on the
quarantine cruise ship the diamond
process well after the 300 Americans
left this morning
and another 400 people from the original
passengers list are in hospitals on on
land in in in Tokyo and others there are
nearly 3,000 people still left on the
ship and their current time period ends
after two weeks this Wednesday so are
they all going to be tested until then
we don't yet exactly know will they
leave on Wednesday or maybe Thursday
there are some questions still open that
might be the reason and some might see
the American decision to take their
people out as as if they have lost
patience in the handling of the issues
by the Japanese officials and also
putting pressure on other governments be
there were Canadians on the ship who
said well your government you Americans
they they take care of you mine just
doesn't care so now we have confirmation
that Hong Kong and Canada will take also
people out which makes up to another 500
and also Australia Italy and Taiwan one
word about the crew there have been
complaints also by crew members who said
we are not under personal current time
we have to work under quite risky canoe
we feel like ya not treated very
properly Clara therefore is in Tokyo
well here in Germany group of people
evacuated from Wuhan have been released
after two weeks in quarantine and 120
people were being held in a German army
barrack since they returned none of them
testing positive for the kovat 19 virus
we spoke to a Red Cross worker who
looked after the evacuees tired but
happy
Oliveira taka from the German Red Cross
listens in to the final press briefing
at the barracks he's one of the Red
Cross workers who volunteered to go into
quarantine with the evacuees from China
now after two weeks of living with the
threat of infection it's time for him to
go home
everyone needed to be a little scared
about everybody else and you have to
make sure you followed the rules you do
it again of course and I think I can say
all the colleagues who are in there
would say the same kind cigars are
ganoush pewterschmidt on the road back
home talker speaks of a tough beginning
after the evacuees arrived back from
China two weeks ago the stress of the
journey all the uncertainty and the
waiting and that after the difficult
situation in Wuhan some of them were
waiting for weeks to get out they were
scared that's why they all fled you
could see that they were relieved to be
here and that relief grew after every
examination which went well at first the
evacuees were divided into small groups
to reduce the risk of cross infection
but the barracks were too small and soon
they were all together so the evacuees
and the volunteers ended up as a
close-knit community despite the face
masks and plastic gloves the crisis is
over for now for Olivet Alka but the
international crisis is nowhere close to
being finished